[Music]
R boots people talking there's in
his one of these days are going to walk
all over you nice all
right do you really give a hoot about
what's in Ron's boot there's a rumor
going around that Governor Ronda sandis
has been hitting the campaign trail with
lifts in his boots lifts I'm not
familiar with this
practice if anything I have to slouch to
to avoid towering over my peers but I'm
told short weirdos sometimes use extra
thick insoles to boost their height when
a far better practice is to add inserts
into your
hair recent footage of his weirdly
shaped boots has only made things worse
but C sis is trying to put the rumors to
rest what they're trying to say with
this is that in your boots you have
heels no no no those are just standard
off the rack um lucazi um how tall are
you how tall are you Governor how tall
5'11 okay why don't you wear tennis
shoes and dress shoes uh I do wear
tennis shoes when I work out wow this is
amazing
stuff the santis is now accused of
height
appropriation he's the Rachel dozol of
stature the Liz Warren of Tall Tales but
obviously the real point to the story is
we live in a society who falsely believe
that tall people are more competent and
happier than short people I disagree
look at these
[Music]
guys and sadly that little guy will
never be president because he's dead but
he's also short Adam yes uh are we
shallow are we a shallow people for
making this a story this is not a real
story I mean it's too bad he's
boycotting Disneyland because he could
finally go on the rides um
but I mean I just think that you know
he's adding three Ines you know
vertically and Chris Christie needs to
take off 30 feet
horizontally but you look people lie I
mean women you know they get fake butts
and implants and the fake eyes I mean so
he could had I mean even Trump said he
was 6'2 215 pounds and I'm like okay and
lizo buic yeah or or Greg Gutfeld says
he's 55 per I'm I'm 5'3 and a half and
you're barely taller than me at all all
right so do you think cat that we will
never have a short president purely
because photo ops it's like people like
when they see Trump towering over Putin
that matters and when he was next to Kim
Jong-un that matters you can't have a
short president uh I would say Never Say
Never I think that it would be better if
he just owned it though he was like I
wear heels you know because the headline
was like he's probably wearing
that would never happen to me cuz I just
expose myself mhm nobody would be like
her hair is probably fake or her bra is
probably padded or she probably wakes up
every morning looking like a young mcau
culan because I've already been very
explicit about the fact that it is it is
and I
do Kennedy uh do you believe that he's
wearing inserts I do I absolutely a th%
really because in the modern era we
haven't had a president shorter than 6
feet tall James Madison was really 5'4
but that was at a time when most people
were 411 so he actually was a giant do
you think was was is Carter over six
feet Carter is 6 fo8 weighs a ton sorry
that was George Washington I take that
back same age though um yeah everyone
every modern president has been tall and
they have hair and D santis has hair but
he's not short like 5'11 is a
respectable height yes you don't have to
try to be but maybe like oh he's
actually 5'7 um but you don't don't wear
the complicated lifts because the the
toes curl up like elf
shoes and then he walks he walks across
the stage like he's Sideshow Bob and
flippers and I I was rooting for him for
what it's worth they're like the shoes
that stick out under the house in Wizard
of
Oz all right Tyrus as a tall person
would you ever vote for a short
president
we have a tall president right now don't
we yeah and the answer is
yeah this is a huge red flag and this
and this I I hope this is just them just
teasing him because if his boots don't
quite fit right but if he is that
insecure as a man to put lifts in his
shoes and try to trick everybody that
means that that's just one little thing
that he struggles with we can't have a
dude like that in the white house
because if you are that insecure to
where you're trying to trick people in a
horrible way like we haven't even
balanced the way to do it yet he's
wobbling all over in his boots like he
didn't even practice like he just
decided to trick everybody well we don't
like that America if you're going to do
it you got to do it right you got to be
like juicy small a you got to rehearse
you got to bring the parts together you
got to make it a thing if if maybe if if
the boots aren't fitting right get wires
bro you know surround yourself with
little people you know like have his all
his Entourage be around
three and a half it's hard for me to do
that plus how funny would it be if for
all the stuff that he has to say about
drag queens he's been wearing heels this
whole time yeah which would be ironic
and again another red flag so yeah I
hope he's not that insecure all right we
tackle that important
Story coming up on screen Hanky Panky
makes gen Z cranky hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else